I saw I went to pitch them at Netflix
the other day boy did I bomb that pitch
I can't pitch the show it's brutal yeah
guy piss the guy off with in like four
seconds Mike's a super politically right
now i alt left Oh was that just homeboy
controller dropping the n-word oh maybe
maybe he said the n-word he didn't say
this yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah and
he said let's not say this word yeah
they said the word yeah awesome
but uh exist Netflix is literally has a
credo they'll tell you oh yeah they have
quotas they're locked in no you have a
TV show we have an Asian director we
have a woman director there so it's not
doesn't matter it's it's it's less about
what happened in your so I had two good
pitches before that so I was loose and I
was zinging and Zhang and I was I was on
and we were in there with the Netflix
guy and we couldn't get the video to
work to play the sizzle and it was just
showing like the ceiling and I go out
it's the Kevin Hart sex tape I'm trying
to make joke and the guy goes can you
believe that the woman is suing him for
that I was like well I think it's the
best thing he's ever done it's funny
it's funny than his specials and he was
like you know I produced the last four
of those I don't think that's
appropriate I mean he does he works with
net flare like oh yeah I'm just calm
just busting balls I love Kevin Hart I
wish I was in he's a little guy and cute
and all that pets to go see it he just
the host pitch poured my heart out in
this pitch shucking and jiving I'm tap
dancing and he was just like thank you
take a joke that's doing something right
though aren't they I mean what do you
think you catch up with it might it
might catch up yeah
you catch knees jumping into it get
these other streaming service jumping in
and yeah they're gonna have some
competition
nah dude Disney doesn't MIT Disney
Disney went on Netflix is how you do it
cool and then they took all their stuff
back and start doing specials yeah well
Netflix now has become a place where
it's all original content right you
can't find no they they have other stuff
like their friends on their right of
Seinfeld are losing friends aren't they
I think but they still have they still
have contracts other stuff oh yeah
yeah just like anything they're the
cream of the crop now but the big boys
are gonna come into yeah it's gonna
level out without the only game it's all
good for us it's all right there's so
many spaces the podcasting stand up we
are we are we are in a really good
finance like this is where you want to
be for the next 10 years I've yeah it's
bittersweet because you got to do the
tweeting and this and that but then you
could also have control of your whole
you know art form this is first time
ever in my in my in my career and in
show business where artists have this
much control yeah and where they're
making all the money it's crazy it's
crazy how much money these comics are
making oh not me but it's nuts wildest
it's the new rock stars is this its what
rock stars worth like now as a comic you
can sell if you can sell 5,000 10,000
tickets which a lot of our friends are
yeah it's sky's the limit
oh yeah it's surprising I let Chapelle
and bird still rock out at netflix
because they're the opposite of that
yeah but that's why opium - Rogan - yeah
but if you got the numbers I guess the
numbers the number I'm being a little
unfair that's true but you know what I
mean lady we got the fan like Chappelle
and rogue are doing arenas you know but
I think Netflix is also I think what
Netflix says I don't know how all left
are what I meant is that Nemzek yeah I
did this is you yeah it's true it's true
I am backpedaling a little people
actually what they were saying is
listening what they were saying is the
old studio system is dead and we want to
revolutionize the way things are done
yes so you know in that sense a little
drone that I don't reason I like that
more people jump into the pool so you
have options you don't want someone just
dominate where if you're not on Netflix
like I you're not really doing well
right I'm with you yeah now you don't
want Netflix have to say like let's say
they pass on mark or they pass on you
right they passed on you it's like and
me both you yeah yeah so then it's like
what the that doesn't make sense to
great comics I'd look at the other
people on there those people are awful
man if funny is the 14th thing on the
list now you know it's like what color
are you what do you have between your
legs
what do you identify as how many Twitter
how many this how's your podcast and
then funny how do you think I got a
special
there you go great car though red
Ferrari unreal
sexy sexy man who's got a he can beat up
everybody - I know you got in you're so
nice yeah you got it all I'm all right
and thick that piece is live scene it
that's like a nerf football I'm not mad
at ya let's get this off you don't
chatroulette oh yeah what is this 1999 I
I we just learned on Monday yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]